[Musique]
Adam, je sais que tu as été
beaucoup déplacé et les choses que je suis sur le point de dire son nom
était
correct quel genre de merde est-ce quelque chose
du placard comme quelqu'un qui est dans le
placard et n'a jamais de barbe  avec vous avez
dit non d'accord
vous avez été de grands bars à crachats vous avez
un ex-petit ami qui pense qu'il est chaud
alors nous devons arranger votre match ils
vont essayer de vous jeter ils
vont se lever dans votre visage
non  vous GL wack ugly je devais juste l'
épeler à faire quand il a eu fini
pouvez-vous garder votre sang-froid je ne sais pas
je regarde votre cou trouvez ce que vous
voulez dire et ce sera le feu cet homme
est un énorme  Les Knicks sont en fait pour balayer
les mots ne correspondent pas à vos actions de
Bruce Lee vous bougez comme votre glaçon
emballant l'Uzi mais vous êtes moins
foutu seulement un peu plus de film de famille le prochain
bon bébé vous êtes un groupe a éclaté un oiseau
de  proie j'ai déjà entendu parler de toi devait
se répandre ta mère a été en contact
elle a demandé à te voir j'ai pensé dans une
manche de sorcier  J'ai des mains magiques longue
chanson Nelly t'entends même comme ça
J'aimerais que tu m'abandonnes à la
naissance comme
ça je me foutrais de toi
c'est juste des mots
[Musique]
toi